So imagine sitting across from a chess grandmaster.
Okay, yeah.
And they're just staring at the board. They don't, you know, mutter to themselves.
Right, they aren't talking it through.
Exactly. They don't write down a list of possible moves on a notepad. They just sit there in total silence.
Just letting the gears turn.
Yeah, the gears are turning in some, like, invisible internal space, and then boom, they make a perfect, devastating move.
The computation is entirely internalized. We only see the final outcome.
Right. Now, compare that to how artificial intelligence usually works today. If you ask a large language model to solve a complex puzzle, it resembles a math student who's forced to show all their work.
Writing out every single step.
Word by word, token by token. And if you want to understand the absolute cutting edge of how AI reasoning is evolving right now without getting bogged down in all the sci-fi hype. That distinction is the key.
It really is.
So our mission for this deep dive is to unpack a brand new paper. It's literally just five days old, posted on August 10th, 2026.
Hot off the presses.
Yeah, it's titled BDH-CQ, In Context Learning with Recurrent Latent Reasoning.
It's a fascinating piece of work by Bjorn Engdahl and a team spanning Pathway, Beelick AI, and NYU.
And to do it justice, we're not just looking at the BDHCQ paper. You brought a stack of five background papers,
right? I did. We need them to provide the crucial context for what this team has actually achieved here.
Because here's the teaser for you listening. We are not talking about a massive trillion parameter behemoth model today.
Not at all.
We are talking about a tiny, like really tiny, 150 million parameter model.
Which is practically microscopic in today's landscape.
Right. But this tiny model just broke the cost accuracy frontier on one of the toughest benchmarks in AI.
And it did it by thinking without talking.
Which is just wild. So let's lay out the headline result. Not the broad AGI height, but the actual measurable achievement here.
Sure. So the headline revolves around a benchmark called ARC-AGI-1. This is a suite of highly abstract visual puzzles. The model is given a couple of examples of a grid transforming into another grid, and it has to infer the underlying rule.
To apply it to a brand new test grid, right?
Exactly. And the breakthrough isn't about BDHC Hue being the single most accurate system in the world. It achieved a 29.5% pass it to score.
Just for context, pass it to simply means the model gets two swings at the bat, right?
Yeah, it generates two attempts at solving the visual grid. And if either one is completely correct, it passes.
Okay, so 29.5%. That doesn't sound like world shattering on its own.
Right. There are models with higher scores on that metric. The real story here is the efficiency.
Because the numbers on that efficiency are staggering.
They really are.
I mean, it took roughly 0.85 H200 GPU seconds per task.
Which is incredibly fast.
Yeah. And when you translate that compute time into dollars, it's a computed cost of $0.00007 per task.
Less than one-tenth of a cent.
That is just unprecedented.
It really is. Let's look at a major player for scale, like GPT-5.6 Luna.
Specifically the low compute tier.
Right. That model scores thirty four point two percent on this same benchmark, but it costs point zero four zero dollars per task.
So even after OpenAI did that massive 80% price cut just a few weeks ago on July 30, 2026, BDHCQ is still about 11 times cheaper.
Yeah. And if you go by the original July ARC price figures before the price cut, it was roughly 57 times cheaper. That's
insane. So the Coreto Frontier, that curve. plotting the absolute best accuracy a system can achieve for a given cost it just got shattered
completely broken through no plotted system reaches at least that accuracy at an equal or lower cost
so the accuracy per dollar metric just moved by more than an order of magnitude yes and it came from a model so incredibly small would usually just go completely unnoticed
Which tells you the frontier of AI development just fundamentally shifted. It's not just who has the biggest computer anymore.
It's who has the most efficient architecture.
Exactly. And that massive leap in efficiency suggests it must be operating in a fundamentally different way under the hood.
Which brings us to the deeper claim of the paper. It thinks without talking.
No intermediate language tokens whatsoever.
Like our chess grandmaster from the beginning. It removes the constraint of having to narrate its thoughts.
Right. In standard AI, that narration is called chain of thought.
And chain of thought forces the AI to route every single intermediate thought through a discrete, limited vocabulary, right?
Yeah, it couples reasoning to serial narration. BDHCQ just removes that constraint entirely. It looks at the puzzle, lets the state evolve internally, and spits out the answer.
OK, but how? The technical mechanics of how they achieve this have to be brilliant.
They are. When the model looks at the demonstrations, the examples of the puzzle, it doesn't just compress them into a single static task vector like a normal system might. Instead, it continuously updates a recurrent memory. They call this the state or saint.
And it updates demonstration by demonstration. Then, when it's time to solve the actual query, it iterates in a structured, high-dimensional, latent workspace.
Known as HR.
Exactly. HR.
Let's unpack that term for a second. Latent workspace. Because it just means a hidden continuous mathematical space, right?
Yes, exactly.
The AI is navigating this multidimensional topographic map of concepts, shifting values around rather than typing out English words.
It churns in this continuous space, iterating its thoughts, before executing a single decode at the very end to produce the visual grid.
And importantly, no parameters like no weights inside the model are updated during this inference time.
None. Furthermore, neither the task identifiers nor the specific evaluation task hairs are in the training data.
So it's purely reading the context and reasoning mathematically.
Yes. And the authors actually bring in a compelling neuroscience connection to justify this design.
Oh, right. The Fedorenko and Varley paper.
Yeah, from 2016, which found that in the human brain, language and thought are physically not the same system.
Which makes sense, but we often conflate our inner monologue with our actual reasoning.
We do, but the brain uses distinct neural networks for them. BDH-CQ is mimicking that biological separation.
and that biological inspiration is deeply embedded in its roots. This is where we should probably bring in our first background paper.
Kosowski et al.' 's 2025 paper, The Dragon Hatchling.
What a name.
I know. But that paper introduced a post-transformer architecture built on locally interacting neuron particles and sparse positive activations. OK. But the most crucial element was its working memory. It uses Hebbian synaptic
plasticity.
Right. Because standard AI models use what's called a key value cache to remember the context of a trumped.
Which acts like saving notes to a temporary hard drive.
But head bean plasticity is biological. It's the whole principle of neurons that fire together, wire together.
Exactly. The model temporarily strengthens the actual mathematical connections between its artificial neurons based on what it's seeing.
So the dragon hatchling proved this localized, synapse-strengthening architecture worked for matching UPT2 class models and language tasks.
And what the BDHCQ paper does is prove that this same brain-inspired architecture pays off for complex, latent reasoning, not just language.
Building a continuous thought space is an incredible feat.
Yeah.
But, you know, reading through our background stack, I do have to push back a little on the novelty here.
Okay, let's hear it.
Because there was a recent fair paper from Meta by House et al.
in 2024 called
Coconut.
Yes, coconut. The closest precedent for reasoning in continuous space.
Right. Coconut took the last hidden state of the model and fed it back into itself as the next input embedding. They called it a continuous breath first search.
Yeah.
Instead of picking one word and walking down a single corridor, it was like pouring water into a maze to explore all possible paths simultaneously before committing.
That's a good analogy.
So isn't BDHCQ just repeating what coconut did?
It's a fair question, and the BDHCQ authors address Coconut directly. There is a real disagreement between the two approaches.
Oh, really?
Yeah. BDHCQ pushes back hard on Coconut's methodology. They note that Coconut's gains depended heavily on a staged curriculum. Ah. The meta team literally had to train their model to progressively replace verbal steps with continuous thoughts over time.
So they needed training wheels.
Exactly. And BDHCQ points out that when you look closely at Coconut's own study, their curriculum controls recovered much of the result.
So BDHCQ didn't need that staged intervention. It just ingests the visual demonstrations and goes.
Right. And we see similar contrasts with other rival approaches trying to escape the token bottleneck. Take Geiping at all from 2025. They scaled test time compute by taking a recurrent block and unrolling it to an arbitrary depth.
Right, like 3.5 billion parameters on 800 billion tokens.
Yeah. But BDHCQ argues that Geiping's line of work treats recurrent depth merely as a trick for parameter efficiency and test time compute.
Whereas BDHCQ is actually learning a transformation.
Yes, from the demonstrations at inference time, it's actively working within that latent workspace.
Okay, but let's examine the strongest direct rival, because this one is tough to ignore. The Hierarchical Reasoning Model, or HRM.
Ah, wang it all. 2025, out of sapient intelligence.
Right. HRM achieves a much higher accuracy on ARC-AGI-1.
It does. It scores 40.3%.
From a tiny 27 million parameter model, beating OpenAI's O3 mini high, which got 34.5%. Yeah. So on the surface, that completely eclipses BDHCQ's 29.5%.
If we isolate raw accuracy, HRM is the clear winner here. But we have to look at the mechanics of how HRM operates, specifically that it is transductive.
Okay, let's make sure that concept is clear for you listening. Transductive learning means that before the model can even evaluate the puzzle, it requires a per-task backward pass adaptation. Right. Every time it encounters a new puzzle, it stops, does a full backward pass, and literally retrains its
own internal weights to create a custom identity embedding just for that specific problem.
It's like a student cramming for an exam by literally rewiring their brain for question one, then entirely rewiring it again for question two.
Which sounds exhausting for a computer.
It is. Because of that intense localized optimization, ARC Prize costs HRM at about $1.48 per task.
Wow.
Yeah. Compare that heavy lifting to BDHCQ's $0.00007.
So the contest here isn't accuracy versus accuracy.
Not at all. It is train a completely new solver for this specific puzzle right now versus BDHCQ's paradigm of read the demonstrations and go.
Okay. That makes sense. But since BDHCQ is just reading the context and reasoning without rewiring itself, how do we get it to try harder on a tough puzzle?
That's the cool part.
Because with a language model, you just prompt it to write a longer, more detailed chain of thought.
Yeah.
But BDHCQ doesn't use words.
Right. The researchers found that latent reasoning effort scales like a dial.
Literally like a dial.
Yeah. Even with no tokens emitted, you can command the model to iterate longer within its latent workspace. Okay. When they set the effort dial to LW, the pass at 2 score was 21%. Which is still
decent.
Turn it to medium, it hits 27%, crank it to high GH, and it reaches that headline 29.5%.
That's wild. Effort improves performance even when the model isn't allowed to narrate. It is just churning the mathematical state longer and getting smarter.
And the cost scales linearly too. Medium saves 11% on cost compared to high GH and low W saves 22%.
Still, a 29.5% score leaves a lot of room for error.
It certainly does.
We need to question whether the model is actually grasping the underlying rules of these puzzles or if it's just finding clever shortcuts.
That introduces the consistency gap. The researchers rigorously tested this by evaluating the model on concept arc.
Which is a specific subset of tasks organized by core concepts, right?
Exactly. And on concept arc, the model achieved a test pair accuracy of 77.92%.
That seems incredibly high.
It does. But when they measured strict whole-task accuracy, meaning the model has to get every single test input correct for a given puzzle to pass the score plummets to 59.38%. Oh,
wow. So it can solve part of the puzzle but fails to apply the rule universally.
Specifically, 52 out of 160 tasks have one or two correct test inputs, but the model fails to solve all of them to complete the overall task.
Think about what that implies. If the system truly induced the underlying rule of the puzzle, for example, recognizing that all the blue squares need to move down until they hit a wall, it would transfer that rule perfectly to every single test input in
that task. The fact that it gets one variation right and the next variation wrong means it hasn't fully grasped the universal logic.
It hasn't achieved true rule induction. And we see further evidence of this uneven understanding when we look at its capability profile.
OK, let's break that down.
Conceptor is divided into 16 concept families. The model's performance across them is heavily skewed.
Skewed how?
Well, on spatial concepts like filled not filled, top-bottom 2D, and extend to boundary, it excels.
Like completing 9 out of 10 or 8 out of 10 tasks perfectly.
Yeah. But on concepts that require manipulation, like copy and order, it completely fails, managing only 2 out of 10.
That is so weird. Why does it master filling in shapes but fail so spectacularly at copying them?
The researchers wanted to find the exact breaking point, so they built controlled generalization ladders.
Ladders.
Yeah. They took operations the model was good at and operations it struggled with and systematically made them harder.
Okay, so pushing it to its limits.
Exactly. For boundary propagation and copying, the model extrapolated perfectly. It scored 48 out of 48 on held-out outputs, no matter how far they pushed the distance within the tested range.
So what happens when they ladder up an operation it struggles with, like ordering?
If ordering hits a definitive wall, the model maintains performance up to a sequence length of five. Right. but at length 7, it collapses to 8 out of 24. Ouch. At length 8, it drops to 1 out of 24. And they observed a
similar cliff with nesting, you know, putting shapes inside of shapes.
Yeah, the Russian nesting doll logic.
Right. It holds up perfectly to a depth of 4, but at a depth of 5, it falls completely.
That's fascinating.
But here's the most interesting intervention. The researchers discovered a way to fix those breaking points. They call it a supported context.
Okay, what does that mean?
If the model consistently fails at a nesting depth of 5, you don't need to rebuild the architecture. You just add one single demonstration in the initial prompt that shows a nesting depth of 5.
Just one example at the target complexity.
Yes. Adding that one supported context caused performance to skyrocket. Depth 5 nesting jumped from 19 out of 24 to a perfect 24 out of 24.
Wait, really? Just from one example?
Yeah. And for length 8 ordering, adding that single supported context lifted the score from absolute 0 up to 13 out of 24.
That proves that the failure isn't a lack of raw cognitive capacity in the latent space.
Exactly. The limiting factor is the coverage in the examples provided. If the context gives it permission to extrapolate that far, the model can do it.
And the actual visual signatures of those failures are incredibly telling too.
Yes, they look very different.
Like when the model fails at ordering, the output grid just becomes a chaotic mess, right? The dimensions are totally wrecked.
Completely wrecked.
But when nesting fails, the model keeps the perfect visual structure of the shapes and just makes one tiny localized relational error.
It understands the grammar of the nested shapes, but it loses its spatial mapping when the sequence gets too complex.
Okay, but what happens when you combine rules? Because the complexity has to multiply when we look at composition.
It does, but you might assume the difficulty just stacks linearly. Composition actually proves to be highly representation dependent. It's not a single scalar difficulty.
Give us an example of how that representation dependency plays out.
Let's take three independent skills, relocation, reflection, and rotation.
Okay.
The model can solve 72 out of 72 tasks for each of those alone.
Perfect score.
Right. And if you compose rotation with relocation, asking it to spin a shape and move it, it stays flawless at 72 out of 72.
Makes sense.
But if you compose reflection with relocation, asking it to flip a shape and move it, performance drops to 47 out of 72.
So it loses the ability to perform those operations simultaneously.
It gets worse. The most extreme example is color swapping.
Okay. What happens there?
On its own, the model only solves 26 out of 72 color swap tasks when you ask it to compose color swapping with relocation.
It solves zero out of 72. It completely breaks down.
Zero. Wow. Before we analyze what these breakdowns mean for AI intelligence as a whole, we should definitely credit the rigorous methodology of this paper.
Oh, absolutely. The rigor is worth crediting.
The authors had co-authors from Beelick AI and NYU conduct an independent black box audit.
Yes, they reproduced that 29.5% score without ever having access to the model weights.
Which is crucial for trust in these numbers. They also performed an opaque identifier application.
Right, by hiding the semantic tags of the tasks, they proved the system wasn't exploiting descriptive task IDs or concept-degrouped bashes to cheat.
It scored 96 out of 160 with opaque IDs versus 95 with semantic ones, so virtually identical.
Furthermore, repeated requests yielded bite-identical results, proving the latent reasoning is perfectly deterministic.
So the scientific rigor is unimpeachable. They proved the model isn't cheating via IDs, and they transparently mapped exactly where its reasoning fractures.
But zooming out, we have to confront the sharpest tension in this entire evaluation. We do. Is a tiny, highly efficient model scoring 29.5% on ARC actually demonstrating generalized intelligence? Or is it just a highly optimized pattern
mantra?
To answer that, we turn to our final background paper, Francois Chalet's 2019 treatise on the measure of intelligence.
And Chalet actually created the ARC benchmark.
Right. And he defines intelligence as skill acquisition efficiency.
So it is not about the breadth of what a system already knows.
No, it is about how efficiently that system can learn a brand new skill from sparse, unfamiliar examples.
And Chile issued a very specific warning in 2019.
He argued that if you give a model massive amounts of specific training data or unlimited priors, you can buy skill in a way that perfectly masks actual generalization.
The model looks like it is reasoning on the fly, but it is really just retrieving deeply ingrained patterns from its massive training set.
Exactly.
Let's point Chile as warning directly at BDHCQ. The authors are very open that BDHCQ trains on a highly curated proprietary ARC style mixture.
very curated. They fed it the RCGI-1 training set, RER, ConceptArc, ArseHeavy, RCRN, 100K, plus private data.
The model is absolutely marinated in ARC-shaped puzzles.
It is.
So the critical question remains, is a cheap 29.5% score actually skill acquisition efficiency in Cholet's sense?
Or is it just skill bought with a mountain of highly specific data?
Right.
Well, the honest evidence points heavily toward the skeptical reading. And to the author's immense credit, they provided the exact evidence required to make that critique.
You mean the paper's own consistency gap and the composition failures?
Yes. The failure to apply a recognized rule across all test inputs in a single task and its bizarre failures in composing simple rules. It indicates it hasn't fully induced the abstract logic of reasoning.
It has basically just learned the visual statistical patterns of A or C puzzles.
Exactly. It resembles a student who has memorized thousands of specific IQ test questions rather than actually increasing their fluid intelligence.
So the team at Pathway and their collaborators engineered a vastly cheaper, incredibly innovative reasoning engine. But the fuel they poured into that engine to achieve this 29.5% result was heavily skewed toward the specific test it was taking.
But here's the thing. While the training data was hyper-specific, we cannot dismiss what the BDH architecture itself has achieved.
Because of the cost efficiency.
Right. Cost efficiency might be the axis that truly matters as we move forward.
Since we are in an era where raw accuracy on benchmarks is increasingly just bought with massive unsustainable amounts of computing power.
Exactly. A 150 million parameter model breaking a cost frontier says something very real and very disruptive about the potential of latent reasoning architectures.
Even if its current performance relies heavily on ARC specific data.
Right.
So it represents a massive leap in how models compute, even if the depth of what they're computing is still limited.
That's a great way to put it.
We should probably recap the honest limits that the authors themselves acknowledge.
We should. First, the internal training recipe is proprietary, meaning we can't look under the hood to see the exact data mixture.
Right. They also haven't even attempted the much harder ARC-AGI-2 benchmark yet. It's completely untouched.
And fundamentally, a system that only solves two out of three test inputs on a puzzle has not actually mastered rule induction.
So it is a significant architectural milestone, not the finish line for artificial general intelligence.
Definitely not the finish line.
Which leaves us with a pretty provocative final thought.
Oh.
Yeah, we started by picturing the chess grandmaster making a devastating move in total silence.
Right.
If AI models continue to move toward this latent reasoning paradigm, you know, thinking in continuous high dimensional spaces rather than English words, what does that mean for our ability to control them?
That is the big question.
Currently, we rely heavily on chain of thought to monitor AI. We force it to talk to itself so we can read its logic and catch its mistakes before it acts.
But if the most efficient, most powerful future models think entirely in an untranslatable, nonverbal mathematical space.
How will we ever audit their reasoning?
How will we ever know what they are truly thinking in the silence before they make their move?
It poses a profound structural challenge for AI safety and interpretability moving forward.
It really does.
Something to mull over.
Yeah.
So keep questioning the data. Keep looking behind the efficiency curves. And thank you for taking this deep dive with us.